[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen tralee trails
halte will ich mal richtig schönem
wetter in einer richtig schönen kulisse
und zwar bin ich gerade in österreich
hier gefällt es mir auch richtig gut ich
bin gerade in salzburg und zwar weit vor
kurzem in wien unterwegs und hab da
einen vortrag darüber gehalten was sich
denn so mache das heißt wie habe ich
meinen youtube-kanal aufgebaut wie
schafft man es einen youtube-kanal
erfolgreich zu führen wie schafft man es
langfristig einen blog zu führen und da
halte ich seit zwei jahren regelmäßig
vorträge vorträge bei firmen aus der
lebensmittelbranche zum beispiel aus der
süßwarenbranche aus der küchenbranche
oder auch an universitäten hochschulen
an schul vor schulklassen und so weiter
und wir werden da immer wieder
eingeladen und ich nehme diese termine
auch immer sehr gerne wahr denn dann
sitzen da die ganzen firmen und die
vorstände und ich darf praktisch aus
meiner sicht erzählen wie das ganze
funktioniert vor schulklassen ist mir
natürlich besonders wichtig die
verbraucherbildung das heißt damit
einfach schüler erkennen wo sie zum
beispiel inhalte auch kritisch
hinterfragen müssen bei firmen ist es
zum beispiel so musterhaus küche wurde
auf uns aufmerksam und hat gefragt sally
wie hast du es geschafft dass wenn man
immer den suchbegriff küche ein gibt
dass man dann deine videos findet und in
wien habe ich auch den vortrag gehalten
und zwar vor der lebensmittelbranche da
waren dann wirklich ganz viele firmen
wie zum beispiel globus und dort habe
ich die aktion mit globus vorgestellt
die seit zwei jahren schon läuft das
heißt bei globus das ist bei uns ein
richtig toller supermarkt aus der region
auch und auch deutschlandweit verteilt
da gibt es alle zwei wochen ein rezept
von mir auf dem youtube-kanal von globus
das rezept kann jeder kostenlos
anschauen man kann die rezept karte
kostenlos im globus-markt mitnehmen oder
auch online einfach herunterladen und in
dieser vortrags runde war zum beispiel
auch hinter spar interspar ist ein
supermarkt sowie globus nur eben in
österreich bei den vertragskunden ist
das meist auch so dass eben gefragt wird
mensch sally was ist denn dein konzept
dahinter
und ich würde mich doch echt gern mal
hinstellen und sagen ja das war alles
super geplant vor fünf jahren habe ich
mir gedacht so brauche ich das ganze auf
aber im prinzip war es einfach nur
es ist einfach alles so passiert das hat
natürlich viel mit disziplin zu tun viel
mit ehrgeiz murat hat mich vor allem
immer super unterstützt von daher muss
ich immer sagen es gibt gar kein konzept
ist einfach so passiert und das mitten
auf unserem leben
ich habe mir jetzt gedacht okay
interspar hat interesse an uns und das
war auch echt super nettes gespräch aber
ich möchte natürlich auch wissen was
steckt denn hinter diesem unternehmen
denn bei globus weiß ich zum beispiel
die setzen sich wirklich für die region
ein die setzen sich für die bauern vor
ort ein
die haben wirklich faire
arbeitsbedingungen fähre arbeitslöhne
und das ist mir natürlich auch immer
super wichtig von daher sind wir zehn
salzburg hier direkt an der zentrale und
schauen uns jetzt gemeinsam mal dem
interspar kommt mal mit
interspar hat insgesamt 63 filialen in
ganz österreich und über 10.000
mitarbeiter das heißt es ist ein großer
arbeitgeber aber dennoch ein
mittelständisches familienunternehmen
hier seht ihr also die lokalen helden
die regionalen produzenten haben die
möglichkeit ihre produkte direkt im
markt ford anzubieten lokal heißt in
diesem fall alles im umkreis von 50
kilometern
und das finde ich richtig gut denn
hiermit zeigt in dessen verantwortung
unterstützt die regionale wirtschaft und
unterstützt vor allem die kleinen bauern
und produzenten von da war das beste
[Musik]
also laura warum bist du hier ich war
einkaufen europa-park meine familie
und dann habe ich sie alle gesehen und
dachte ich mir oh mein gott das
nachzählen weil ich sage ich muss die
videos kennen und erfahren dass sie zu
treffen
extrem so man rechnet damit nicht und
dann dachte ich so 'oh mein gott dann
war habe ich euch gesehen beim drehen da
dachte ich weiß du dich jetzt hingehen
oder milch mal nicht wieder nicht
unterbrechen aber es war richtig war
das ist doch schön und was machst du
jetzt mal mit dem schmalen weitergehen
also ich getroffen habe und noch ein
bisschen weiter ein kauf
[Musik]
die cellistin gestern des post gelesen
auf facebook und ja und da malt ihre
chance genutzt einmal in salzburg die
zelle live zu sehen
[Musik]
beim interspar findet man im prinzip
alles was man fürs alltägliche leben zu
hause braucht oder auch alles was man
gerne verschenken möchte was ich hier
ganz toll finde bei uns ist gerade beim
schulstart auch hier in österreich und
hier kann man jetzt in praktischen schul
listen service nutzen das heißt man gibt
die schul liste ab was das kind zum
beispiel zur einschulung oder auch für
die nächste klassenstufe benötigt und
kann dann später ein paar tage später
einfach das fertige päckchen abholen
[Musik]
die filialen haben auch ihre hauseigenen
metzgerei und die tragen das gütesiegel
das siegel bedeutet man kann
nachvollziehen woher das fleisch stammt
hier stammt zu 100 prozent aus
österreich
es werden unabhängige kontrollen gemacht
und das fleisch hat eine ausgezeichnete
qualität
[Musik]
und lecker hier gibt's ja auch frisch
gemacht ist so schön so über den globus
kann man zu gucken und dann auch direkt
probieren
ja gerne
[Musik]
ich probier s mal mit stäbchen
das klappt glaube das sieht aber lecker
aus danke
[Musik]
doch
mo
danke
[Musik]
die interspa märkte haben ihre eigenen
backstube und hier arbeiten
bäckermeister und sie bilden auch ganz
viele lehrlinge aus bei ihnen merkt man
wirklich dass die aus leidenschaft
packen es gibt ganz viele tolle brote es
gibt brötchen semmeln sagt man hier
glaube ich dazu es gibt bis mit rouladen
es gibt kuchen und torten und ich werde
jetzt gleichauf vorne was probieren nur
kurz vorweg es gibt acht bäckereien und
tief machen die brote wirklich vor ort
aus der region und die beliefern dann
die backstuben
[Musik]
die station hier finde ich jetzt richtig
süßes gibt es nämlich einen klosterladen
mitten im interspar und zwar leitet
pater dr johannes traurig dass europa
klostergut eichin fand gilgen und zwar
hat er dort einen kräutergarten angelegt
einen heilkräutergarten die kräuter
werden dann geerntet und dann werden sie
einfach zu verschiedenen produkten
verarbeitet zum beispiel einfach
heilkräuter jahresverlauf sei als spröde
oder zum beispiel auch kräuterlikör und
die produkte werden hier auch verkauft
nicht nur in seinem hofladen und das
ganze kommt dann einfach dem kloster zu
gute von doch das beste so heißt winter
sprach und ich habe mir heute morgen
gedacht mensch will noch die produzenten
wirken hier aus der region kommen kenne
ich doch bestimmt heute auch einen
spontan interviewen und es hat jetzt
echt super geklappt neben mir steht die
paula paulus man konnte heute leider
nicht kommen ihr habt die mosterei
laster hier in der umgebung und er
konnte nicht kommen weil ihr praktisch
gerade sagt presse bekommen habt genau
aber super geklappt und wir bisschen
übung zum übrigen also mich würd's
interessieren wahrscheinlich auch meine
zuschauer
was hat sich denn verändert seit er den
etat spar beliefert und was hat sich
denn gebracht also welche chancen habt
ihr denn dadurch bekommen ja wie es
freuen uns sehr dass wir das machen
können verändert hat es natürlich dass
man ein bisschen der produktion her dass
die maschine besser ausgelastet sind und
auch dass die leute wie er oft anrufen
wir uns unseren wo bekomme ich das noch
weil es haben nicht alle autoren sind
natürlich sehr froh wenn sie dann
irgendwo hingehen können ja dann kann
ich sagen beim interspar bekommen sie
unsere sätze ab sofort gibt es bestimmt
auch im schönen hofladen oder uns gibt
es einen hoch werden soll
also freut euch die zusammenarbeit und
sass er ja fast jeder eine sehr positiv
für das freut mich weiterhin alles gut
sogar schön und ich werde natürlich auch
einen bach mit nach hause nehmen welche
kannst du dir empfehlen wahrscheinlich
alle wahrscheinlich alle produkte dieser
wieder abgeschafft
sagt und firmen also das wird bei uns
schon seit 60 jahren erzeugt also nehmen
wir den auf gmbh man mir sagt naturtrübe
ist ganz naturbelassen also ohne
zuckerzusatz nur gepresst und
pasteurisiert super da nehme ich dann
auf jeden fall mit
das beste heißt auch beim niki mir geht
du hast auch ganz viele produkte beim
interspar was zeichnet in seine produkte
aus ja unsere produkte zeichnet
vielleicht aus dass spezielle jetzt in
dieser region unsere kühe unterwegs sein
und er ist fotograf hier dadurch beste
mich und dann wirklich ein wunderbarer
remigen jersey milch käse und erzählt
ihr habt also käseprodukte was habt ihr
denn noch
wir haben hauptsächlich krise und
dadurch dass wir alle drei haben auch
haben wir vieles mit allem korrekter
unter anderem eben auch die angler in
käse drin in frischkäse oder schnittkäse
auch beim kuhmelken zum beispiel und das
haben dann auch hier in diesen flaschen
in allem kräuter mit allen könnte leben
oder mit albumcover salz sagen wir
natürlich in salzburg legitimiert für
unser salz dass man sich seiner
regierung
was hatte ich dann noch so bewegt die
produkte bei interspar an verbieten
in klarer sprache ist sehr bemüht
regionale produkte
im sortiment aufzunehmen wir haben ja
weniger zufällig kontakt aufgenommen
gegenseitig und es ist immer so wenn man
merkt dass wir die produkte haben will
und dass er damit der freistaat tue das
nicht einen der sie nicht leistung gibt
oder so dann gibt man gerne weiter was
man erreicht großes super echtzeit und
achten dass es heute spontan geklappt
hat ja ja das einrichten müssen
irgendso jetzt gerade zu messen was
gemeint
also ich freue mich bestimmt mal
besuchen
das wäre ja dann gibts auch gern auf der
alm bei den kühen biografie vielen dank
danke dir
[Musik]
meine intersport uhr ist leider schon
fast vorbei ich bin auch schon seit dem
morgen unterwegs wir haben gemeinsam mit
dem geschäftsführer und mitte marketing
sind durch den markt gelaufen haben eine
mark besichtigung gemacht ich habe die
getränke vielfalt gesehen und auch die
gewürz welt war alles wirklich sehr
beeindruckend und ich habe euch meine
zuschauer gefragt was muss ich denn
unbedingt in österreich kaufen was es
nicht in deutschland gibt und ihr kennt
mich anscheinend so gut viele haben
gesagt süßigkeiten
ich bin ja auch so eine kleine süße es
gerne süßes und macht auch mal ganz
gerne natürlich nicht zu viel und jetzt
habe ich eure kommentare einfach mal
durchforstet und die meisten haben
geschrieben mana mana produkte kenne ich
auch aus deutschland aber das ist hier
so eine große produktpalette gibt wusste
ich selber auch nicht deswegen muss ich
jetzt ganz viel man da mitnehmen
vor allem für mich meine familie und für
das ganze team
mit
[Musik]
sally bitte nimm schweden bombe mit das
wurde mir auch geschrieben die nehme ich
natürlich auch mit und da gibt es auch
noch richtig coole geschichte dazu die
firma wäre ich fast in die insolvenz
gegangen also wäre pleite gegangen und
dann wurde ein facebook aufruf gestartet
und so wurden wirklich ganz viele
investoren gefunden die firma konnte
aufrecht erhalten bleiben und deswegen
komme ich heute abend auch in den genuss
der schweden punkt
ich glaube ich noch eine packung mädchen
dann kann ich meine tore machen
viele haben geschrieben dass ich
unbedingt ein quiz kernöl mitnehmen soll
bis heute habe ich nicht so ganz
verstanden warum ich habe zwar auch
kürbiskernöl zu hause aber seitdem ich
hier im regal steht weiß ich natürlich
dass es ein kürbiskernöl aus der
steiermark das ist ein bio qualität das
nehme ich auf jeden fall auch mit
und zwar werden da die klubs kerne am
fein gemahlen dann wird es so eine art
teig der teig wird dann gerüstet und
dadurch entsteht der richtig schöne
nussige geschmack und auch die kräftige
grüne farbe
das ganze wird dann später mit der
original steuer presse mit so einem
stempel wirklich ausgedrückt so dass das
hochwertige öl entsteht das nämlich
jetzt mit und ihr werdet euch vielleicht
wurden dann aber ihr könnt wirklich ganz
ganz viele gerichte damit verfeinern zum
beispiel auch vanille eis das hat mir
meine freundin ihres schon mal erzählt
probiert habe ich es noch nicht deswegen
kommt dass mit den einkaufskorb und dann
gibt es daheim eine kugel vanilleeis mit
kürbiskernöl der soloklasse klar machen
wir einen moment hab den handy hatte
schon abgegeben so vom macho zu mir
rüber
ja super
habt ihr schon was mit der künstler so
gemacht ja ja echt was macht man damit
einfach klasse was hast du damit gemacht
gebacken
ps danke und jetzt noch der original
österreichische schokolade bio und
fairtrade
ich hab so viele süßwaren reichen für
heute
jetzt nehme ich noch ein bisschen was
gesundes mit ihr gibt es getrocknete
früchte
koßmehl und anderer zutaten die nehme
ich jetzt mal mit und probier zuhause
einfach anders aus
[Musik]
meine intersport uhr ist für heute
verändert und ich muss sagen ich bin
sehr begeistert und werden uns jetzt
auch geeinigt das heißt meine produkte
gibt ab oktober in allen filialen morath
räumt gerade meinen einkauf schon mal
ins auto
ich habe mich jetzt hier in der bäckerei
gesetzt und zwar gibt die die die die
mauer ist ein österreichischer koch im
guten koch zwar und den beiden abend
treffen und er hat hier eben europark
einmal the bakery da wo ich jetzt eben
die tasse tee trinke und auch schon ein
stückchen kuchen gegessen habe heute
abend werden wir hier auch ein shooting
haben dass wir machen ein kleines
fotoshooting zusammen und werden den
abend gemeinsam verbringen mit meinem
themen mit diddy und auch mit den leuten
von interspar und heute abend werden wir
auch noch oben essen gehen im
idyllischen darin nämlich sein
restaurant und ich denke das wird auch
richtig richtig lecker ich werde die
tasse tee genießen noch eine kleine
verschnaufpause werde mich dann doch in
europa kein bisschen umschauen und dann
geht es für uns wieder zurück nach
deutschland
ich hoffe euch hat das video gefallen
und ich freue mich schon auf eure
rückmeldungen
ich bin mal gespannt darauf wie viele
aus österreich zugeschaut haben
und ja ich denke wir sehen uns dann ganz
bald in österreich in salzburg vor allem
und bestimmt auch an ganz ganz vielen
anderen orten also bis zum nächsten mal
ich glaube die sind heute
[Musik]
[Applaus]
interspar hat insgesamt 63 filialen in
ganz österreich und über 10.000
mitarbeiter das heißt es in großer
großer arbeitgeber
das heißt in der schweiz auch ein
richtig großer arbeitgeber aber dennoch
einen familien- und
ein mittelständisches
familienunternehmen ist einfach gut
das heißt es ist auch ein richtig großer
arbeitgeber aber dennoch ein
mittelständisches familienunternehmen